Trump won without getting you know in
2016 he didn't get the popular vote oh
geez okay well imagine what's going to
happen if RFK runs splits the Democratic
vote and Trump wins with 43 percent this
goes and there was a poll the other day
about abolishing the Electoral College
same thing with this it goes back and
forth depending on who is at the you
know the butt end of the stick right so
in 2000 Bush won but he lost a popular
vote Democrats wanted to abolish the the
Electoral College in 04
um it looked like Bush would win the
popular vote then they wanted to keep
the Electoral College I mean it just
goes back and forth no matter who and
Gallup has been doing that for years uh
that's why when something's in place
like that it shouldn't be up for
National referendum so I hate those
polls they're totally irrelevant who
cares if somebody supports the Electoral
College or not there's a reason for it
we don't want a civil war upheaval let's
keep it you know so
um this can happen again though so I'm
glad you pulled that up